right now we enjoyed seeing his posh
surroundings or at least uh the the the
background behind him as as we saw in
his expert analysis on the ESPN NFL
network coverage made me very jealous to
share this man who loves wearing shorts
and no shoes but just he looks all
business on top and party under and
party underneath he's kind of like the
human mullet Daniel Jeremiah how are you
DJ Thank You first of all I'm it's great
to be back with you I want to tell you
the the phrase mixed emotions is thrown
around a lot and I now have a a perfect
explanation for it and that is this
draft for me because mixed emotions in
that not having you not having Charles
Davis my buddies and we have so much fun
right I mean that sucks but I'll be
honest with you the fact that so many
Michigan players and and so many
Tennessee players were drafted
we're gonna be apart for a year this was
a very thankful that it was this year
I'm hoping next year I get back in
Charleston and get after him a little
bit and give you a hard time but there
would catch your alma mater had so many
players drafted I would have got killed
if we were all together I know there
were ten of them there were ten of them
from my alma mater and it was great to
see and I thought people's Jones was a
steal and you know but there really
wasn't much to talk about in terms of
the one would say pressure points to
this draft with my alma mater at
Tennessee so I want to kind of get into
the the headlines of all this and the
headline what one would say is what the
Packers did how can you walk us through
how things go on a draft room where you
you'd think Green Bay would would draft
a receiver in the deepest wide receiver
draft possible certainly after what
happened on Thursday night and yet they
come away with nothing how does that
happen
well it's interesting how you look at it
I was just talking with Bucky about this
on the podcast which was he was saying
that for his image from the 49er game
right where they got clobbered by the
Niners was the Niners running the ball
down their throats and he came away from
that thinking okay well they wanna they
want to be more physical so that's why
they drafted the big back Dillon from
Boston College that's why they made the
picks that they made on the defensive
side of the ball everything they did to
him was about trying to be more physical
with San Francisco and I left that game
rich thinking they have to get Aaron
Rodgers some more firepower like they
can't compete with these top pop teams
to win the ultimate prize unless they
have more weapons and they obviously did
not look at it that way so that was a
you know that was a little bit of a
disconnect there
the quarterback thing I understand that
from an you know from an organizational
decision if you love if you were you
know huge your love fans and you feel
like he could be the quarterback for the
next 15 years that's that's the long
that's the long view decision and that's
where you say okay the general manager
has has the control because the head
coach if the head coach had control
they're normally thinking about next
year this was not a next year decision
this was the next 15 years oh that's
kind of how that goes down in the room I
understand that I guess but what about
not calling Rodgers again we had Ryan
wood the Green Bay Press Gazette beat
writer for the Packers on the show in
our first hour and he confirmed that
they did not give him a heads up that it
was coming how does that happen
Daniel well the Bears the Bears can
one-up him on that though they don't
even have the best story in the division
when they had who they had Glennon right
that Glennon at like a fan event when
they picked true Biscay and Flacco was
at a fan event right when Lamar Jackson
got picked or something like that and I
understand but this hour
we're talking about I would Aaron
Rodgers it's a different level I am with
you on that if it was me in that
situation I would have had a
conversation with him you know a little
bit ahead of time not like you're on the
clock but just hey if there's a certain
situation with a particular quarterback
is there at the end of the first round
we have to look after the long-term
health of this organization not saying
we're going to pick him Aaron but I just
want you to hear from us that if there's
a particular player there we would
consider taking him and I don't want you
to be blindsided by that you can have
that conversation with them you know a
month before the draft if you want to
but at least you've laid some type of
groundwork some type of communication
there with him so I've got Howie Roseman
on in a final hour DJ what did you make
of the Hertz pick I think it I think
when it first happened it was kind of
shocking a little bit trying to make
sense of it and then the more you think
about it the more you can wrap your mind
around it for a couple of different
reasons number one and how we I'm sure
how we'll lay this all out for you the
one thing I don't agree with is that
there's some of the thought of well we
can play him a little bit and then we'll
be able to spin him off for a pick well
that one doesn't make much sense you've
just been a second round pick on him you
know you're gonna you spin them around
for hopefully you know a two maybe a one
like that it's one thing if you take a
guy in the sixth round and develop him
and then you treated him for a
second-round pick or a first-round pick
like okay that's that's a huge
difference but you took him in the
second round so I don't really count
that what I count is this is the team
that lost a playoff game last year
McHale you know wasn't totally healthy
but they saw firsthand if they just had
a little bit better play at the
quarterback position they win that
playoff game so that's part of it the
second part of it is you've invested all
of this money in your starter the Eagles
have always invested in the backup think
about chase Daniel obviously with Nick
Foles they've put money into that
position well once you pay Carson 100
million dollar deal you don't want to
devote another ten million dollars a
year to his backup now you just got so
much money tied up into one position so
we want a quality player but we don't
want to invest a bunch of money the only
way you do that is with a higher draft
pick so that to me is kind of gives them
some more financial flexibility
at other positions because they haven't
invested quite as much in the
quarterback position I know it's kind of
complicated richer but I think that kind
of all came together into the making the
move that they did no I mean and we're
seeing again
Taysom Hill right we're seeing we're
seeing guys who are your quarterbacks in
quotes come in and perform in
significant manner right and and taking
quarterbacks off the field and the
quarterback that's being taken off the
field in New Orleans is true priests and
that is as high up the flow chart for
goats as you can get you know in many
ways so I I can kind of see it right I
mean you can think about this to think
about this this defense nobody's like
the Eagles have had some different
players come in and out jim schwartz is
one of the best defensive coordinators
in football they have a top five top
seven defense almost every single year
in philadelphia so they're gonna be in
games and if carson wentz misses a
couple games you don't need somebody to
come in there and be carson wentz and
run that whole offense if Jalen Hertz
comes in there makes a couple plays and
you can score 17 points you're gonna you
have a chance to win football games like
he can he can do that without having to
you know put him in the same role and
ask him to do the exact same things
Carson does I think he can kind of get
you through that stretch of game so not
only a little pack I could see them
using packages down on the goal line
he's not going to be like Taysom Hill on
the standpoint takes a pill you know
plays some wing back right blocking guys
like special team right but he can come
in and play quarterback down and though
in package packages or don't read use
him down the goal line like that's what
he would be in that in that role
Daniel Jeremiah my compadre from NFL
Network joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show so I give you the floor the
draft that impressed you the most was
which teams I really there's some there
are some good ones the Minnesota Vikings
I thought nailed it okay when you look
at their first three picks they had two
first rounders last year digs you know
when I looked it up I was kind of
surprised Dick's caught 63 balls last
year I bet you Justin Jefferson will
come in and catch more than 63 balls
this year alright as a rookie he's ready
to go and they
beautifully he's a pro everybody who
talked with LSU raged about this kid so
he's going to come in play right away
starter productive he'll help you offset
the loss of Dix then you go out and get
Jeff Gladney a corner who is feisty and
competitive like the Mike Zimmer traits
that you would write down on a sheet of
paper this guy checks them he's going to
come in start right away a really good
player at the corner position they go
out and get Azra Cleveland it was one of
the most athletic tackles in this draft
now they have O'Neill I want to say
O'Neill ran in like the 4-h it's just a
ridiculous time so you've got probably
the most athletic tackle combination in
the league not saying are the best
players but just phenomenal athletes
that can they can show you tremendous
range in that zone stretch game that
they run with Gary Kubiak you've got
Garrett Bradbury who if he's not the
most athletic Center is one of the two
or three most athletic centers in the
NFL so with Dalvin cook in all these
ultra athletic linemen like in gary
kubiak scheme Dalvin cook in a rush for
a zillion yards next year so i just love
what they did they got guys they fit
them so well and what do you think of
the 49ers draft though they didn't draft
many but they had a big Thursday night
and then Trent Williams gets added
I just think Lynch is just crushing it
man that's what I said just yet but
ironically I was just texting with Shaw
I should tech David back and tell them
that I don't know what to ition is at
Stanford but after that draft I think it
might go up because Lynch has proven
that they teach him pretty well up there
I mean to come out of this to get a
younger cheaper version of DeForest
Buckner and Kinlaw to come away with
when healthy and that's you know it's
been a minute but when healthy and on
the field
Trent Williams is the best tackle on
football when he's when he's right to
get Brandon IU who fits them you know
after run after the catch you know with
him and be Bose and know they're gonna
get Jalen Hurd back that is a lot of
firepower for that group so beautiful
job of trading maneuvering around the
board at I mean John Lynch I thought it
was a clinic Dana Jeremiah here on the
Rich Eisen show what a crucial draft for
the doll
how do you think they fared I would say
I liked it I didn't love it
I thought they had opportunity they
could have done a little bit more with
all their picks now I think what the
fact they got to uh I thought they that
was the right call
I mean I thought he was clearly the
second quarterback so you know you got
to take a little bit of a gamble on his
health but you know you know no risk it
no biscuit right that's Bruce Arians and
I believe in that's all right I think
getting to or there was the right call
Austin Jackson up side you probably had
to take him where you did he's not ready
right now but can be your left hand who
they got a good player but noahic but
noggin either third third round pick he
was like my 70-something player I
thought that was a little early for him
some of these other guys if they went
throughout the draft I liked it I
thought you know it wasn't a home run I
thought it was a good draft if two hits
then that's it's all worth it right
um it was good it was good not great I
thought the team's held the fix I
thought Minnesota was better
I thought Jacksonville you know that's a
reboot they traded all those veterans
and I thought they nailed it I mean
Henderson is really really gifted cover
corner Kayla Vaughn chase on gives them
some more pass rush on the opposite side
of Josh Allen frees them up within gaku
if they want to move him if that thing
comes to an ugly end here
Leviticus Chennault was good value was a
playmaker now they're starting to add
some pieces around Gardner Minshew and
then you know guys like Shaq quarterman
from Miami just really good good leaders
good guys
I thought they kind of changed this
whole feel of this team a little bit
with this draft Daniel Jeremiah are here
on the Rich Eisen show and you know you
were kind enough to mention at the very
top of our conversation that my alma
mater had ten Wolverines drafted in this
draft a fifth of them by Bill Belichick
who loves himself some Wolverines
obviously it took win of its last year -
what do you think of of Bill's decision
obviously to move out of the first round
and then we saw what he did on Friday
night and then what he did on Saturday
and none of them are a quarterback what
do you make of the Patriots draft Daniel
yeah yeah it's funny rich I I looked up
and I think we might have talked about
this last time we spoke but I found this
presentation that a scout had given us
in Baltimore training camp and it was a
yet
for under Belichick and this was a
presentation from 1991 with the Browns
and Belichick had described what he
wants at every single position this is
going back to 1991 and you could
literally pull that out and look at
their entire draft and go he has not
changed one bit like he knows what he
wants he knows what fits him what fits
their scheme and how they play and it
was just right down the list of all
these guys with versatility guys that
can play the run really well he still
values that you know a tight end that
you can move around and do different
things with like the whole draft is just
quintessential Bill Belichick Patriots
just that's who they are not taking a
quarterback
I don't think where they were picking
they felt like they were going to draft
a quarterback that was better than Jared
Stidham so they just weren't going to
spend to pick on a guy that they didn't
think was better than him he was a
fourth round pick he's very talented and
I think they're gonna give that kid a
chance
so maybe the quarterback second day if
you want I know he'd hit on Hertz or
third day that you think has an
opportunity to mesh well with the team
that's drafted him and and and maybe be
a long time starter in this league
it's hard to find them you know I think
when you talk about the the four guys in
the first round and then you go beyond
that you know jaylen hurts I think it
would have to be for another team down
the line would be my probably my first
choice there of guys out of first round
and have a chance to be long-term
starters in the NFL you know Jake from I
just I don't he's he's not a great fit
in Buffalo in terms of being on the
field I think he's going to be an asset
to Josh Allen in the room you know
helping him but I could you know if he's
going to be a starter in the NFL I don't
see it happening in in that in that
environment there I think you'd have to
go somewhere else but probably my
favorite day three quarterback pick
would be the kid that the Jags took and
Jake Luton from Oregon State he's he's
big he's a good decision maker he's
pretty athletic he's someone if you know
obviously Gardner Minshew played well
last year but if he were to falter it
wouldn't be shocked of all today three
guys if he was the one that got on the
field at some point in time next year so
I mean you told me DJ cuz you know Joe
Douglas very well and thankfully you
didn't leave me to go work with him
that this was a Noah's Ark offseason for
the Jets they needed two of everything
why are they using a fourth-round
picking a quarterback why would they do
that well I think when you look at them
last year's you do rich I which I
couldn't believe
when you go back and look at them in
their record what were they seven and
nine right I know they eight Nate
no there were seven and nine I don't
know how they work I don't know how they
work and when you look at the postseason
and you look at the games they had to
play without Sam Donald why he was out
with mono if they had a if they had
better quarterback played during that
period the Jets could have been the
postseason last year which is crazy so
they felt like they had to upgrade that
that backup position and now you've got
an expanded postseason they just you
know if Donald's out a game or two they
just they couldn't trot out there what
they trotted out there last year they
just had to get better and they really
like this kid so that's why they used in
there in the fourth round I think that
you got to look at the Jets and kind of
a two plan phase here this is the first
offseason for Joe Douglas it was about
protecting Sam Darnell
first and foremost which they didn't
free agency and they they they got two
good tackles in the draft and I think
next year where they have a ton of money
in free agency and then they'll have
their assets in the draft I think this
year was about the big guys I think next
year will be Phase two where you'll see
them go heavy on the weapons and who had
the best home draft set up that you
thought let's let's evaluate that Daniel
as you know your job is to evaluate and
everything's an evaluation this time of
year you saw it all during the broadcast
you know I was just there on my on my my
laptop and draft athan while you were
checking everybody out and doing your
evaluation who had the best home draft
setup from your from your perspective
Maxim at money Smith our buddy about
this about Kingsbury Kingsbury's was to
me it was a like require no we're what
was your car like you can smell it yeah
right exactly like this this this this
does have more than just one sense to it
I agree it looks like a Bulgari ad to me
you know like that's that's the way
there's more this is sort of a European
touch to it in a way certainly with that
European cut shirt and no socks and
loafers which is impressive and then
let's let's be honest though has a
better view they both have the paper
thing which I'm looking into my backyard
and I can I don't know if I can get more
than three or four those papers in but
with the grass around it man what a
sweet look and then he has the LA
skyline behind him so McVeigh in the
daylight hours I think his second place
but once the the city lights popped
behind him right man I might go McVeigh
over over kingsbere in an upset how
about Bella checking the dog how about
Bill and his dog about Bill and Nike
that this should be a bill in Nike show
he's feeding the dog he's giving the dog
treats it's fantastic and the table like
to me I was man tight that's not
Nantucket written all over it that's got
Nantucket and along with life table that
has like we just took Eric Metcalf and
I'm fired up I'm gonna go buy a new
kitchen table and he stuck with it he is
the same table that he had back then he
is rockin now and I appreciate that and
then you did know
you you you did the shorts thing right
all weekend long did it you didn't put
on a stage oh yeah you know I'm actually
wearing jeans right now and I feel like
I'm not succeed oh look at your setup I
mean we're looking at right now the
socks no pants all business on the top
party underneath the top the socks do
you match the tie the E or you've got a
very interesting carpet situation now
but the flowers whose touches that is
that your wife's the flowers mine this
is NFL Network sending our talented crew
out here they put the flowers behind me
the lamp the flowers the whole thing oh
this is none of mine none of this stuff
is mine come on dude the flog
I got a setup no they don't bring me
flowers they don't bring me flowers they
don't bring me flowers anymore you did
not know I had that Club in my bag I
definitely knew Mayock didn't did you
see what they out did when I asked him
to send me his when I asked him to send
me his draft setup did you know about
that
daddy you heard about this and I said no
I don't want your outside picture I want
your inside picture you just text back I
know what you meant
that was it that's the last I heard of
him I haven't heard from him since I
give you my can I give you my Mac
interaction paragraph go for it
so he takes he takes rugs right yes so I
text him I said speed exclamation point
right mm-hmm
so then that that's right after the
pickle I don't send him anything after
he takes our net he doesn't reply to the
speed thing Thursday night 10:48 p.m.
speed yeah plus your 8th ranked
quarterback exclamation point so he was
he knows exactly your evaluation he
knows exactly I love it man
you're the best Daniel great job what
you had to say about Mort to was so
heartfelt and beautiful just beautiful a
whole thing soup too much DJ really I
appreciate you now let's get to
Cleveland buddy I mean I know our band
back together and have a lot of fun but
I mean honestly you
represented all of us at NFL Network's
so well so expertly and made everybody
proud to be able to call you colleague
sir great job well I appreciate you
thank you so much Richard you did a
wonderful job raising a ton of money and
the videos that some of the videos that
I saw he could see it live but the Tom
Brady stuff was it was great undrafted
fine live thanks again DJ we'll chat
soon okay that's Daniel Jeremiah hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here